[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local aujourd'hui il y aura comme
toujours des analyses des débats et des
duels endiablé cra quatre chroniqueurs
sont autour de cette table pour
m'accompagner à présentations ont
tendance à ma droite elle nous vient
tout droit de versailles alliant
toujours avec sa bonne humeur et de la
répartie elle est spécialiste de ' pole
dance notre ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange où le plaisir de
venir une nouvelle fois sur cette
émission je suis ravie j'étais pas là la
dernière mission vous m'avez manqué mais
je suis de retour
belles années 2020 est important juste
le bonheur c'est bien c'est déjà le
bonheur la joie est trop de l'année 2020
entre les deux oui c'est déjà bien on
passe de l'autre côté musique c'est un
petit nouveau dans l'équipe aujourd'hui
il fêtera sa troisième apparition ce
passionné de saint-etienne est
aujourd'hui titulaire après avoir fait
quelques entrées en jeu remarqué
stéphane de visée sera avec nous pendant
une heure également stéphane comment
allez-vous très bien tout va bien on se
remet à gagner
tout va bien alors ou sur l'homme
méchant handicapées wiimote sur l'eau
pour moi parce que je suis très méchant
très méchant très méchant si je peux
faire souffrir les gens c'est avec un
véritable plaisir
d'ailleurs j'ai pas mal de conneries en
stock
d'accord on note sans merci entre
toujours selon l'émission petit à petit
je vais les livres et continuer à
regarder l'émission
on passe de l'autre côté musique qui
nous vient à tout droit de versailles
aussi un titulaire indiscutable de cette
émission il arrive à nous éclairer avec
ses analyses et ses anecdotes pierre
chevalier du rugby-club de versailles
est avec nous salut amical et salut a
tous formés bonheur bonjour pierre quand
allez-vous ça va super bien
stephen a l'air d'avoir un stock
quelques ça permet d utiliser toute
petite joute avec des valises à blagues
plein s'arrête se parfaire sa promesse
on termine de l'autre côté musique c'est
une légende l'un des piliers de cette
émission porte on le connaît on ne peut
que l'adopter la semaine dernière et
nous l'a promis il sera très sage en
2020 genlis ex-entraîneur du rugby-club
de plaisir c'est avec nous quand
allez-vous gens très bien très bien
oui très bien que vous avez votre ami
stéphane a ôté la en forme
oui il a les enfants mais puis louis
michel a dit donc non mes films alors
avant de passer au programme de
l'émission commence par une information
à cyclisme le coureur colombien de 23
ans et gagnent bernal sera dans les
yvelines au mois de mars le vainqueur du
dernier tour de france a confirmé sa
participation pour le prochain paris
nice et sera au départ de plaisir
objectif défendre son titre acquis l'an
dernier il a enregistré une vidéo pour
ses supporters de l'as du landas bonjour
à tous je voulais vous dire que je serai
présent sur le paris-nice 2020 je suis
impatient d'y retourner et faire une
belle course pour vous je me prépare en
ce moment spécialement pour cette course
on se voit là bas la draille ce qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
c'est une bonne nouvelle forcément
pierre chevalier c'est au mois c'est
moins bien pour la fiche dire on se
plaint souvent que sur certains
événements sportifs il manque des têtes
d'affiché on parlera pour certains et
pour certains sports un peu plus tard
dans l'émission est donc là c'est bien
pour se réjouir pour le
laura et la portée médiatique du du
paris-nice d'avoir un tout bon champion
en ce moment c'est presque le meilleur
sur sur tout l'est sur toutes les
grandes compétitions et notamment sur la
grande boucle donc bien pour bien pour
l'organisation bien pour le pour la
course et bien pour les yvelines puisque
paris nice par deux par deux chez nous
donc c'est très bon stéphane de bien
vous êtes un fan et colombiens
totalement et je ne vis que par lui
depuis que j'apprends qu'il va être au
départ du paris nice et du bonheur total
comment vous ne dormez plus c'est ça
c'est ça en fait
qu'est ce que vous pensez de se couvrir
maija gagner le tour de france ça va
faire du bien pour la ville de plaisir
ça va faire venir du monde encore plus
de monde je pense
et puis ça va faire une pub énorme puis
je crois que là il a signé pour cinq ans
et c'est une étoile montante du cyclisme
donc non je pense que c'est très bien
pour pour le cyclisme genre je suis
comme stéphane gilli pareil alors il a
remporté l'année dernière le paris nice
également forcément il veut conserver
son titre
hellemmes je pense qu'il peut on à villa
pour commenter mais voilà il est en
début de carrière est de rire c'est
coûte rien aujourd'hui
non mais je pense qu'il peut a offert à
ce que ça donne
est ce que vous pensez qu'il vient
repérage pour le tour de france
également pierre je sais pas exactement
le même tracé donc je pense j'ai eu pas
sur un peut-être uniquement sur la
partie ambiance et sur la partie porté
par les supporters français c'est pour
ça que le
la petite vidéo qu'ils bossent tête
assez finement vue parce que c'est pour
justement se manifester auprès du public
français se mettre déjà dans les bonnes
conditions ils arrivent en arrivant
gagnant en vainqueur du tour de france
et du paris nice dont je pense je pense
pas que ce soit une préparation pour le
pour le tour de france en temps mais en
tout cas c'est une c'est une beau
message pour le public français alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de foot us les templiers
d'elancourt ont repris la saison de
deuxième division par une défaite nous
ferons également un coup de projecteur
sur le mma en france ce sport longtemps
interdite devraient être légalisés dans
les prochains mois dans l'hexagone
une bonne nouvelle pour les milliers de
pratiquants yvelinois mais avant de
développer ces thèmes
on va parler rugby du rugby donc pour
commencer cette page résultat un choc
étaient au programme de cette 14ème
journée de fédérale 3 versailles
recevait bobigny au stade de boersch
fontaine ce dimanche 26 janvier deux
équipes au coude à coude dans la course
au top 4 en fin de saison
malmenés en début de match les versets y
concède rapidement des points et sont
menés 13 à 0 au bout de 22 minutes de
jeu les bleus arrivent à revenir dans la
partie avec un drop inscrit le score à
la pause 13 à 3 en seconde période
versailles pousse à la faute les jours
de bobigny les joueurs de la cité royale
marque mais c'est les versaillais
reviennent à hauteur après cette
pénalité et marque
cette nouvelle pénalité dans les
dernières minutes du match score final
16 à 13 pour versailles
les gars ont eu du coeur ils ont trouvé
les solutions et avec du mouvement et
d'intensité on a réussi à passer devant
sur la fin de match
versailles est désormais troisième avec
41 points et peut rêver plus grande
écoute l'un des joueurs s'est passé
quelque chose franchement on savait que
c'était un tournant et
on est contents si on maîtrise bien la
suite de la saison je pense c'est
quelque chose à jouer une qualification
est envisageable
on n'osait pas trop en parler mais avec
ce second bloc il faut s'accrocher 1
s'est pas fait mais on y pense
pierre chevalier votre analyse de cette
rencontre tout d'abord avant de parler
plus globalement de la suite de la
saison de versailles alors c'était
effectivement un tournant parce que
c'était donc ça ça se fait par blocs en
fédérale 3 par bloc de trois matches et
là c'était la possibilité d'une part de
finir un blu victorieux avec trois
victoires de suite et donc de vivre
vraiment définitivement bien commencer
l'année 2020 et puis de se placer
vraiment de s'installer dans les quatre
premières places de la poule puisque les
quatre les quatre places premières
places sont qualificatives en plus des
huit meilleurs cinquièmes surtout le
surtout le championnat de fédérale 3
donc l'analyse c'est que c'était un
match c'est un match compliqué c'est un
match piège bobigny est une très bonne
équipe qui est depuis longtemps en
fédérale quel a été ton fédéral une puis
deux puis trois mais a gardé quand même
une très beau fond de jeu est vraiment
de des bons gabarits
là pour le coup qui nous ont mis qui
nous ont mis sur les fesses du pendant
toute la première mi temps on a mis du
temps à rentrer dedans et à les contenir
et aller plaquer
et finalement ça bascule en notre faveur
signe que signe que la période est bonne
sur le sur le surf de l'année des de
l'année dernière de la saison précédente
on a on a un groupe on a un groupe qui
est solide
ceux qui sont arrivés en cours de saison
en intersaison se sont bien intégrés et
comme dit gaby pêche le il ya quelque
chose qui s'est passé et en plus on
était vraiment attendu 3 13 à la mi
temps c'était pas fait c'était pas gagné
et ont ils le gagnent ou mentale et
et là on s'installe vraiment bien dans
la course à la qualification ils vous
ont surprises sur cette rencontre
ils m'ont surpris dans la capacité de
réaction est d'une certaine manière de
d'orgueil d'être mené sur son terrain
il faut rappeler qu'on a on a perdu on a
perdu un match de match à la maison
contre la c b contre celui-ci on est
allé gagner à celui-ci pour pour
compenser un petit peu ça la cbb on
verra bien en fin de saison donc il
fallait qu'on reste maître maître chez
nous mettre à la maison c'était pas un
bon scénario des bars jusqu'à
d'habitants et et capacité de réaction
et ce groupe à ce groupe a un petit
supplément d'âme qui permet de gagner
ces matches au couteau
la question sur ce thème le club at-il
fait le plus dur avec cette victoire je
rappelle que maintenant le club et 3e du
championnat
bobigny son adversaire jo est 5e le plus
dur pour l'as pour la qualification
jeudi par rapport aux motivations pour
la suite du championnat
pour finir dans le top 4 oui c'est vrai
oui c'est vers hélène première édition
aujourd'hui ça mais genre je sentais
sceptiques
non je peux passer petite palud près ce
qu'ils ont fait le podium du championnat
sur pour lexus de la question était là
je peux sceptiques du tout simplement on
le voit fréquemment ce genre en équipe
qui fait ça fait déjà trois saisons à
peu près je crois qu'ils soient ensemble
le groupe et qu'ils ont des belles
performances et qu'ils ont des résultats
et on le voit fréquemment ces clubs
d'honneur qui monte aux donneurs et qui
font des grosse saison en honneur font
émerger après lisant son premier
inversée et proment la sanef ont la
plupart ludin de très belles saisons en
fédérale 3 dans la foulée
parce que justement il ya cet engouement
il ya ce cette spirale de victoires qui
fait que le groupe se fait et comme le
le joueur qui change c'est le capitaine
mais le joueur l'a dit sur l'interview
quelque chose qui s'est créé accuse
souvent quelque chose qui se crée là on
voit par rapport au classement que en
battant mobinil dimanche ils les ont mis
à 8 points
il met bobigny à huit points donc on
peut dire qu'ils ont déjà un pied dans
la qualification dans les quatre
premiers
après après c'est autre chose après on
fait quand on en parlait mais là pour
moi la qualification en battant batam
aubigny d'image
ils ont mis un pied dans les quatre
premiers et bobigny à un an et à huit
poèmes de de versailles ce soit
difficile de remonter parce que c'est
quand même ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
qu'ils gagnent les deux victoires de
plus que versailles sur la fin de
championnat donc un peu plus compliqué
là et versailles a fait une très belle
opération en images pour moi pierre
chevallier langue pour vous c'était le
maintien
oui c'est un bout du coup je dis stop
pour l'instant c'est qu'on l'avait dit
en début de saison l'objectif d'un promu
et sans langue de bois c'est tout le
c'est toujours le maintien
il se trouve que l'appétit venant en
mangeant et sur la dynamique que citer
jean la dynamique de groupe
on peut maintenant entrevoir beaucoup
mieux et notamment notamment une
qualification
on a fait le plus dur sur le maintien ça
c'est quasiment acquis
il faudra quand même énorme coup de
trafalgar plusieurs coups de trafalgar
pour que pour que pour que ça pour que
ça n'arrive pas mais sur la sur les
partis politiques qualification
troisième sur quatre les quatre premiers
sont pris voir les huit premiers les
huit meilleurs cinquièmes sur le reste
du championnat donc il ya la haine là
aussi un bon une bonne place qui a été
prise et qui sera qui sera maintenue qui
sera bataille et deviennent alesi gens
fous rires pour faire chier un signe et
le chien chinois l'année qui s'est
beaucoup après c'était fait de viser moi
je n'ai pas le courage de les contredire
ils ont totalement raison qu'est ce
qu'ils ont à faire pour pour maintenir
l'équipe sous pression à votre avis
parce que comme le disait pierre
justement ben apparemment ils ont le
mental pour redresser la situation mais
les 13 0 gagné 16,13 faut en avoir dans
la tête ça veut dire qu'ils ont là la
capacité de jouer un cran au dessus
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas jean en
le sait la différence de niveau entre
l'honneur et la fédérale 3 les haut de
tableau d'honneur ont le niveau fédéral
3 donc le
la différence n'est pas énorme et moi
moi ça me surprend absolument pas la
saison de versailles parce que comme je
le dis souvent les clubs qui font des
grilles des belles belles des grosses
saisons en vain on a réussi cette saison
en fédérale 3 après sous pression je ne
pense pas qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
sous pression parce que je pense qu'ils
sont plutôt là d'une spirale positive et
le groupe effet le groupe heavy bien ça
ça se voit pas ce que lorsque on perd 13
3 à la maison à la mi temps face à une
équipe avec lequel on se bat pour la
qualification et on revenir et passer
devant et gagner ce match ça veut dire
que le groupe lié la queue il n'y a pas
de pression justement il ya ces larmes
c'est encore mieux parce que je pense
que s'il se met la pression
c'est là où ils vont commencer à bégayer
et cela ils vont commencer à jouer à ne
plus jouer leur jeu leur jeu de
solidarité qui à mon avis est le leur
actuellement
est ce qu'on les attendait là déjà des
saisons la question à pierre ce qu'on
les attendait pas donc pour l'instant
tout est bonus tout tout est venu jouer
et oui tout est mis longtemps
on va là on avait juste viser le
maintien et on s'était pas prononcée sur
ce qu elle a peut-être un jour sortir le
liban de lévis en chine sans empêchement
c'est à dire ses gardes là vraiment la
cohésion comme ils ont l'énergie comme
ils ont ils se connaissent suffisamment
les techniques
voilà ils savent et c'est ça qui va les
mener
à performer plus ces avancées maintenant
ils sont déjà ils ont déjà prouvé la la
remontée les on attendait presque pas
une remontée comme ça d'un autre club on
l'aurait pas forcément entendu mes deux
de leur entente et de leur largeur
ensemble ça a été possible
il n'y a pas forcément besoin de
maintenir sous pression il reste lui
journée la yemenia une petite trêve
jusqu'au 16 février pendant les matches
du tournoi des six nations
il ya suffisamment dangereux ils se sont
fixés suffisamment dangereux eux pour
bien figurer maintenant que maintenant
on connaît le potentiel réel de ce
groupe et que la mayo a pris ils se
montrent en gros il se monte la pression
entre mai mais une pression positive une
pression une pression collective qui
leur donne envie d'aller plus loin et
c'est on a on n'a pas soufflé quoi que
ce soit à gaby pour dire que désormais
la qualif c'est l'objectif est
maintenant on est on est tous on est
tous groupés derrière hellemmes
l'équipe ii verset 20 dans les 3e est ce
que ça peut jouer également sur la suite
du championnat c'est à dire que l'équipe
sera plus attendu pour l'instant
l'équipe des conseils communs comme un
promu je peux maintenant c'est peut-être
qu'on sait qu enfin l'équipe est
considérée comme l'une des meilleures
peut-être de la foule on est derrière
finalement oui puis tout le monde est
derrière les supporters et ceux qui ont
envie de les porter son derrière à
attendre que ça continue et que ça ça
même plus que ça se maintiennent donc ça
monte et je pense que les équipes
adverses qui sont au dessus et qui vous
rencontrez doivent se poser quand même
quelques questions et
vont être obligés de faire un peu
attention tout pour les battre toujours
bateau sur tout ce qui monte d'un coup
on se dit bon dans cela ça peut jouer ou
à votre avis ça peut jouer fait je ne
pense pas que versailles est l'équipe
qui était prise à la légère depuis le
début de la saison savait pertinemment
les clubs les clubs je vous dis le
niveau le niveau le niveau là versailles
on savait pertinemment de versailles
avait largement le niveau fédéral 3 et
les clubs c'est fait c'est pas c'est pas
il a tenu coi la position de versailles
ne me surprend pas bon pas pas du tout
puisque ça non
syrte est aussi un chevalet c'est que
dans notre projet global on a fait ce
qu'on avait dit c'est à dire qu'il y à
il ya une bonne dizaine douzaine de
juniors montant de l'année dernière et
de l'année d'avant qui sont dans les
deux groupes seniors dans les groupes
seniors ii seniors 1
donc ça c'est aussi un clin d'oeil à la
formation à la formation versaillaise
avec tous les tous les encadrants qui
font du bon boulot dans toutes les
catégories jeunes de l'école de rugby
jusqu'en seniors pour accompagner
justement nos joueurs formés au club
en première les leurs questions sur sur
versailles votre pronostic pour la fin
de la saison
stéphane de bizet ils vont aller
jusqu'où le plus dur c'est de confirmer
ça va être ça pour eux donc donc je sais
pas il faut voir la suite genre ce que
ça valait fication se faire après des
qualifications oui pour moi et je les
dis je les dis un début de saison pour
moi qualification oui après si on veut
parler d'eux
d'un exploit parce que là ce serait
quand même un bel exploit c'est à dire
la montée en fédérale 2 là c'est une
autre paire de manches mais parce qu'il
ya quand même la cvb sur la route
puisque c'est par secteur et si ça va
changer un accueil qui va monter dans ce
secteur là et c'est il faut se qualifier
pour les huitièmes il faut que tu passes
les allers-retours 32e aller-retour 16e
ouais sauf que sauf que lorsque jusqu'au
1/8
c'est par secteur ne le sait c'est la
poule contre la poule 2 donc il va
falloir passer un énervement il faut
passer à la cbb qui fait figure quand
même de d'épouvantail d'épouvantail et
de gros favoris avec invaincu depuis le
but de la saison donc mais après le
ratage
le pronostic pour moi il montrant pas
cette année mais se qualifiant pierre
kalisz tomber en 32e je rejoins ce que
tu dis à mon avis la montée c'est ça
risque d'être un peu dur on continue à
jouer jusqu'au bout de la santé vassyl
qui vous fasse mentir
alors on continue par du foot us et
templiers d'elancourt ont repris la
compétition ce samedi 18 janvier les
landes courtois accueillis au complexe
sportif europe les léopards de roi
l'occasion pour les joueurs évinois de
montrer les muscles et le potentiel de
l'équipe dans cette 2e division tout
tout championnat bien débuter quoi mais
dans une bonne un bon rythme dans une
bonne dynamique une bonne dynamique pour
bien débuter la saison quand c'est
important de bien commencer donc au dos
et commencé par une victoire ce serait
bien pour la suite des événements va
dire mais le match ne tourne pas en
faveur des élans courtois les joueurs
locaux sont dominés et perdent la partie
sur le score de 22 à 9 l'objectif de
montée en fin de saison n'est pas encore
remise en question mais les joueurs
devront à trouver rapidement des
automatismes pour emporter à des
victoires
un mélange d'anciens et de et de juniors
qui venait qui sont issus des des
sections jeunes qui venaient polluer
d'un fonds après ma saison en senior
donc ça change un peu donc voilà pour un
temps d'adaptation
voilà à quoi faut qu'après je pense que
quand ils ont pris leurs marques qui
pourront bien là il prend la porte à des
clips quoi alors je vous rappelle
l'historique des templiers joueur évolue
en deuxième division depuis quatre ans
et ont toujours un espoir de montée en
fin de saison à chaque fois il échoue
lors des playoffs
l année dernière l'un des joueurs
alexander sa song avait annoncé avant le
début de la saison de monte et une
victoire 50 à 0 contre les aigles équipe
qui s'achevait en playoffs finalement
alors il avait gagné de justesse sur le
premier match qu'ils aillent perdre en
play off contre ces gladiateurs nature
en briques la question sur ce thème les
templiers sont ils un reparti pour une
saison galère
oui ou non oui voulait pas défend les
templiers
ça c'est que ce j'ai pas envie de penser
j'ai pas envie de dire qu'ils sont
partis pour une
une saison galère mais sa part pas très
bien il ya des mouvements dans l'équipe
c'est ça m'a pas l'air très bien engagé
genre bah oui en fait ça fait plusieurs
fois
cancon coquillât le thème des tabliers
et c'est vrai quand c'est la première
fois cette saison
oui oui mais plusieurs fois dans
l'émission nous avons déjà parlé de
s'appuyer
donc non malheureusement à fait après
bon c'est l'histoire ne se répète pas
j'espère pour eux mais malheureusement
ils ont du mal depuis quelques saisons
et je suis pas sûr que il se met
les vraiment les les ingrédients pour
atteindre leurs objectifs
on voit beaucoup d'espérance dans ce
groupe
et puis on voit peu de résultats avec
vraiment les résultats qui sont
chaotiques
quand même aller en playoffs oui il
imaginait ce fait je fait méchamment y
apparaît dans mon équipe et je pense que
aller en play-offs n'est pas on parlait
du réduit juste avant sur une poule de
douze y en a que quatre qui vont les
phases finales 4 sur 12
je suis pas sûr qu'au football américain
le le rapport à la convention sur la
même
je pense qu'à beaucoup beaucoup plus
équipe par rapport aux nombres qui font
les offres pour continuer la saison donc
aller en pleurs pour moi je suis pas
spécialiste du football américain
mais aller en play-offs au moins n'est
pas une reconnaissance est vraiment de
gros résultats sur la saison mais moi je
leur souhaite
je leur souhaite beaucoup de bien mais
c'est vrai que en force le constater
qu'ils ont ils ont du mal puis thomas le
second depuis que anderson est parti
avec une personne qui était chroniqueur
dans cette émission qui est parti au
japon entraîné l'équipe de handball
stéphane de mise et qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mais il commence c'est en
galère pour vous je pense qu'ils sont
partis pour une saison galère
mais comme disait ce sportif il n'y a
pas de mayonnaise entre les anciens et
les jeunes qui arrivent pas encore oui
enfin le temps qu'il aura pas quelque
chose de dur je pense qu'ils vont être
dans le moule il voit dans le
chevallier elle a dû se passer quelque
chose s'il a dû se passer quelque chose
justement pour amollir un dipôle d'où
notamment avec des départs et puis des
retraits vous dire des retraites du
président réjean chagos président
historique du club avec ses fonctions ou
qu'on voyait souvent qu'on voyait
souvent ici c'est quand même c'est quand
même étonnant dont c'est la deuxième
fois qu'on en parle de cette saison et
on en parle chaque saison et c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois c'est le faux-départ en
sur lequel on avait gagné de justesse
l'année dernière leur premier match mais
après après après une pause de décor qui
était déjà un petit peu plus ambitieuse
au moins dans les dents les dans les
paroles mais dont il a dû se passer
quelque chose et ils sont dont ils sont
tellement dans une phase de
reconstruction que pour l'instant je les
vois pas encore au bout du tunnel mais
mais en travaillant et en et en
intégrant les jeunes pousses ont faisons
en sorte que les uns et les autres
jouent ensemble
je suis d'accord avec jean c'est a
priori de le fait de se qualifier pour
les play-offs n'est pas forcément un
exploit dans le championnat français
mais
mais c'est tout ce qu'on leur souhaite
et de pouvoir retrouver leur rang à
condition de comme on l'évoquait il ya
deux ans de commencer par l'humilité et
puis derrière c'était by step de
remonter en première division
les templiers d'elancourt sont en phase
de transition peut-être élèves je suis
dans les transitions on espère mais il
va falloir vite faire connaissance vite
que la mayonnaise prenne vite qu'eux ils
sachent jouer ensemble et trouver des
voies là des actions ensemble parce que
si c'est cette année qu'il faut qu'il
faut faire quelque chose et pas que ça
rebouge l'année prochaine si ça rebouge
tous les ans que l'équipe et est
reconstruite déconstruit et reconstruit
et nouveaux de l'ancien ça ils seront
toujours sur cette phase ii on aimerait
faire des choses mais on n'y arrive pas
et c'est décevant pour eux après ils ont
un autre problème également ce sont les
jeunes qui partent généralement très tôt
des templiers d'elancourt il les formes
et ils partent ensuite aux états unis ou
au canada pour pratiquer leur passion
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faudrait
peut-être un petit peu les retenir jean
oui mais ça c'est le les joueurs prendre
l'équipe de france par exemple
voilà bah c'est le propre de tous les
clubs
qui feront les joueurs et qui voudrait
dire obtenir mais est ce que le club a
les moyens de retenir ces sportifs et on
a tendance à dire moi qui suis en train
il faut quand même favorisé le haut
niveau aux jeunes
donc les laisser évoluer aux templiers
sens surtout les dénigrer mais c'est
peut-être pour leur avenir sportif
il vaut mieux quand même qu'ils aillent
s'aguerrir au canada aux états unis
quittent après pourquoi pas à revenir à
apporter au club mais est ce que le club
leur a donné parce que ça se fait
beaucoup dans d'autres disciplines
et c'est peut-être aussi ce qui leur
manque actuellement pour pouvoir
franchir peut-être cette marche c'est
justement des joueurs qui sont d'un
candidat au niveau au moins un ou deux à
des postes clés alors que là ils font
d'après ce que disait le directeur
sportif qu'on a écouté il ya beaucoup de
2,2 d'intégration de jeunes de juniors
et donc il faut le temps que ça prenne
et si en plus dès qu'ils sont formés et
des meilleurs s'en vont c'est compliqué
de garder un groupe homogène et
performant sans mettant une star en
quarterbacks pour ne dire que ça voilà
qui reçut ali je pense qu'il ya un
paramètre qui diffère par rapport à
d'autres sports et notamment à la
difficulté de retenir les jeunes pousses
ses propres aux sports américains
principalement le football américain le
baseball par exemple qui sont qui sont
très très spécifique de l'amérique du
nord et du canada et cc n'y a guère que
la houle est justement les jeunes
peuvent s'acquérir aller se frotter aux
meilleurs se former éventuellement
revenir après mais il ya une telle
différence de niveau entre les états
unis le canada et l'europe pour le foot
le foot us et le et baseball qu'on ne
peut pas qu'on ne peut pas blâmer les
jeunes allaient vouloir se former là là
où c'est là où c'est mieux on n'a pas
cette on n'a pas touché ce cas
ouais ouais aussi je pensais au hockey
aussi ok sur sur glace notamment où là
il ya un type aussi en russie dans les
pays de l'est mais on a on n'a pas ce
cas en rugby ou la nouvelle zélande féfé
la nouvelle-zélande et l'australie fait
fait office vraiment de d'eldorado mais
on a un niveau quand même relativement
élevé en foot
en football football rugby en europe et
en france pour pouvoir garder nos
meilleurs jeunes après sur le football
américain est sur le baseball c'est plus
difficile parce que parce que le niveau
niveau des reins est un niveau vraiment
inférieur par rapport aux états unis
représentés essayez donc ça bouge - il
n'ya pas l'émulation comme aux états
unis ou et je pense que les jeunes qui
performent qui apprennent et qui ont
envie de jouer
ils ont envie de connaître le gros match
l'ambiance et les fins côtoyer les
grands joueurs et c'est qu'on n'a pas
vraiment aidé les templiers d'elancourt
joueront leur deuxième match de la
saison le samedi 1er février contre les
myrmidon de sa vie le temps toujours à
domicile une équipe qui a remporté son
premier match de la saison contre nantes
on passe maintenant notre page coup de
projecteur
une bonne nouvelle pour le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'open de
france sera bien organisé à dans les
yvelines du 2 au 5 juillet un temps
pressenti pour être déplacé dans le sud
de la france sur le golf de terre
blanche dans le var les organisateurs de
l'european tour finalement décidé de
confirmer le sitv noah jean-loup charron
le président de la fédération française
de golf s'est félicité de cette décision
chez nos confrères de l'équipe
la dotation de l'événement ne devrait
pas dépasser les 2 millions d'euros
l'open de france est organisé à saint
quentin en yvelines sans interruption
depuis 2002 et devrait le rester au
minimum jusqu'en 2023 la question sur ce
thème une bonne nouvelle ou pas pour les
yvelines oui pas de débat aujourd'hui
genre vous a été une nouvelle fois le
premier à dégainer
allez-y bah oui c'est bien pour les yeux
ça c'est sûr puisque c'est à vue un gros
beauf nationale qui est quand même si on
dit que les yvelines est une terre de d2
vélo mais elle est aussi de golf à
travers ce magnifique complexe et que le
golf national de guyancourt
il ya une vingtaine de golf également
dans les wilayas me alain paquet il y en
a un paquet mais il est particulière il
est particulièrement un joli succès il
est quand même très joli et
et très très technique donc comme c'est
très très bien pour les yvelines
et puis je pense aussi qu'ils ont ils
ont ils ont pris la décision de le
maintenir ici parce que je pense qu'il y
a qu'ici où ça fait fera vraiment
beaucoup de spectateurs et je crois que
c'est ce qui les a un petit peu effrayé
le fait de le déplacer parce que c'est
le côté habituel le côté rendez-vous
pour beaucoup de gens et le côté aussi
pratique d'accès et voilà l'habitude
l'habitude
après bon ce qui est ce qui est à
déplorer c'est malheureusement que l'on
risque de ne pas avoir un gros plateau
par rapport à la récompense c'est ce qui
va faire le petit petit bémol eu
justement vous avez vous fait la
transition jean est-ce que c'est pas
finalement un cadeau empoisonné
serre chevalier c'est le meilleur
compromis tout cas pas bien c'est lui
faire cadeau c'est le meilleur compromis
d'avoir d'avoir pu ou d'avoir su le
déplacer en juillet on a vu les dégâts
que ça pouvait faire sur l'affluence de
les déplacer en octobre comme en 2010
neuf mois on a vu à linverse à quel
point c'était s'était dopé si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
en 2018 pour l'open de france puis
évidemment pour la ryder cup qui s'est
joué sur le même parcours en septembre
2018 donc c'est le meilleur compromis
oui
il ya un tournoi international à néant
sur le circuit américain sur le world
golf championship en même temps au sein
de jude invitationnal donc il va pas se
mettre des meilleurs dotation je crois
de 10 $ ses pharaoniques et ça veut dire
que tous les meilleurs américains et
européens seront là bas du tour européen
seront là bas donc c'est le meilleur
compromis à la poire en deux on a on a
une on a théoriquement une des bonnes
conditions climatiques on a de quoi
faire une belle édition
alors allez vous l'assuré le oui il y
aura des français il y aura des français
c'est sûr peut-être peut-être pas les
meilleurs du moment comme un victor
perez qui sera sûrement peut-être lui
sur le sur le circuit circuits
américains invités habituels soir
alexander levy romain en gaz que seront
là seront là à n'en pas douter
donc ça va faire une belle édition c'est
du bon réceptif
c'est bien pour le golf pour les c'est
bien pour les yvelines c'est bien pour
la fédération française de golf
c'est bien pour les licenciés aussi
comme le disait jean c en ile de france
qui a le plus de licenciés en france de
golf et tout ce petit monde a bien de
vraies et à financer d'une certaine
manière aussi tous les travaux et tous
les embellissements du golf national
notamment pour recevoir la ryder cup
donc c'est très bien que pour trois ans
encore au moins pendant l'open le plus
vieil open delà de l'europe continentale
soit organisé sur le golf national
stéphane de bizet vous qui êtes un
amateur de golf également totalement
j'adore ce sport on est sur une vraie
bonne nouvelle je n'avais pas de
nouvelles c'est ça et sinon je suis
d'accord
alors certains vous voulez peut-être
abandonné cette formule de l'open de
france formule un peu classique pour
créer une super super tournoi au tournoi
qui réunira les meilleurs avec une
grosse dotation est ce que ça serait
éventuellement la solution pour combiner
le golf national le meilleur goal de
france avec les meilleurs joueurs
oui probablement
vous êtes d'accord moi je suis d'accord
genre est ce qu'il faudrait faire
déborder l'open de france pour créer
cette super tournoi
oui mais ça veut dire qu'on va retomber
dans une autre date série va falloir
trouver une autre date parce que l'on
peut pas la peine de venir là puisque
pierre vient d'expliquer aux intentions
des rumeurs pour qu'au même moment il ya
un super tournoi avec 11 millions de
dollars à la clé donc ça veut dire que
si on fait en fessant supprime open de
france et qu'on crée une nouvelle
compétition trouver une autre date le
choix net
moi je peux faire le choix dans la date
parce que c'est vrai que là en la
fédération était mécontente de la date
de l'an dernier en octobre en larmes et
mois de juillet l'assaut de dire qu'on
refait encore marché machine arrière
place à sam a pour moi ça manque un
petit peu de sérieux je crois qu'il faut
le maintenir en espérant que mais ça ça
reprenne ça reprenne ses marques et que
ça redevienne une belle compétition et
que sarah attire du monde
je pense qu'il faut insister pour que le
monde revienne et non pas la supprimer
non pas faire machine arrière pour ma
part ça dépend ce qu'on vise est ce que
c'est une affiche pour le golf français
ou le fonds européen ou est ce que c'est
une affiche pour le golf international
il ya trois ou quatre ans il y avait
encore des qualifications pour l'open
s'il ya tous les tous les golfeurs même
amateurs pouvaient pouvait se contenter
de se qualifier pour le pour l'open de
france donc c'était vraiment l'open
national et qui permettait de drainer le
golf professionnel et golf amateur
notamment en france il est vrai que
depuis il ya un certain nombre de dates
qui se et de tournois internationaux et
notamment américains dg a qui se sont
mis en face il ya une forte concurrence
désormais on a aussi en plus le problème
du le problème du sponsor titre qui
devrait être qui devrait être le même
que l'année dernière donc amundi depuis
le retrait des deux justement ça ne
devait pas la chandelle
c'est là la cms que le sponsor ne doit
pas être ses forces et un allemand ces
labos la boucle est bouclée c'est que le
problème c'est qu'on a on a une date qui
fluctuent on a derrière on a on a aussi
des gros trop en face et donc pour
l'instant la fédération peine à trouver
un sponsor qui s'installe qui met
suffisamment suffisamment sur la table
pour voir s'installer sur les 3 ne
serait ce que sur les trois années à
venir mais ça dépend évidemment de la
date du plateau et ça dépend trop de du
du parterre médiatique que pourrait
avoir ce sponsor pour pouvoir durer
hellemmes nouveau sponsor sinon le
l'open de france va connaître en
déclenchant une nouvelle dotation il
faut moi je pense qu'il faut soins oui
soit un nouveau sponsor soit des moyens
beaucoup plus importants et en effet
arrêté de fluctuer avec la date est
arrivé à gérer ça avec le calendrier
international du golf parce que si on
n'a pas les têtes d'affiché si on n'a
pas une dotation assez importante
ce fin c'est un tournoi qui restera pas
forcément advitam eternam en un mot de
boxe maintenant la carrière de tony hawk
eye pourrait prendre un nouvel élan
levy noix de 27 ans devrait signer
officiellement dans les prochains jours
avec bob arum le promoteur américain est
à la tête de la société toprak une
entreprise qui travaille avec les plus
grands boxeurs de la planète et
notamment un certain tyson fury ce
partenariat yoka arômes devrait ouvrir
au boxeur de chanteloup les vignes les
portes des combats aux états unis d'un
possible championnat du monde
le bilan de joka chez les professionnels
est actuellement sept victoires en sept
combats la question sur ce thème fait-il
le bon choix
oui mais pas de débat aujourd'hui ok
fait de bons choix genre et on va dire
oui parce que dans ce monde le monde de
la boxe
s'il n'ya pas s'il a pas un sponsor
puissant si on ne pousse pas à à monter
à c'est avec ça qu'ils pourra prétendre
à aller chercher un éventuel titre
mondial
sans ça il ne pourra pas y restera il
restera j'ai repris dans l'ombre mais
presque c'est les promoteurs c'est
l'argent c'est ccc lui proposer des
combats autres à mon avis parce que bon
je suis pas un grand spécialiste de la
boxe mais j'aime bien regarder la boxe
et je me connais un petit peu
il n'a pas eu pour l'instant sur ses 7
premiers combats énormément de 2-2-2 de
gros gros adversaire quand même il a
quand même fait sept combats pour 6 ko
quand même oui
non je suis d'accord ouais mais si c'est
contre le boucher du coin et le forez le
foraine de la fête à neuneu
bon honnêtement au niveau de la boxe et
il apprend contrairement pour moi de
réelles de ré l'adversaire de réel
adversaire de deux vrais de vrais grands
boxeurs donc pour l'instant sain des bus
est c'est à nous tous dans le milieu
professionnel
mais c'est pour moi puisque la question
c'était est ce qu'il a fait le bon choix
oui parce qu'ils s'aiment passage
obligatoire pour pouvoir grandir dans ce
milieu d'après midi mais je suis
d'accord avec jean c'est un bon moyen
pour passer une étape pour viser plus
haut
il s'est fait remarquer et c'est ce
qu'il faut et maintenant il faut qu'il
avance est en effet qu'il rencontre des
adversaires plus forts plus fort en
règle générale est aussi plus fort que
lui pour qui est de la progression est
ce que c'est pas trop tôt finalement
stéphane non non ce n'est jamais trop
tôt s'il s'en sent capable qu'il y aille
et puis voilà il a 27 ans il a 27 ans il
n'est pas encore où sa carrière
mais bon puisqu'il veut tenter mais
qu'il y avait maintenant il faut pas
oublier qu'il est laid à l'échelle
olympique l'échelle mondiale dont il a
remporté deux médailles d'or aux jo de
rio nos bêtises voilà il est illégal et
il est né médiatiquement notamment et
sportivement évidemment ça c'est qu'il
savait un certain nombre d'années qu'il
était sur des sur les rings mais on a
entendu parler de tony yoka sur le sur
la scène internationale et donc sur sur
une victoire à une médaille olympique ne
faudra pas pu se parler en france
finalement qu'à l'international abbas
est une chanson beaucoup de fierté
oblige évidemment chauvinisme et fierté
oblige c'est comme ça aussi qu'on a
appris qu'on a appris qu'il existait et
qu'il est qu'il était performant avec sa
compagne de l'époque aussi en même temps
et et là c'est justement cette capacité
à gérer la transition et le passage vers
le monde professionnel qu'il a déjà
enclenché depuis depuis quelques temps
mais c'est comme dans tous les sports il
falloir qu'ils aillent et qu'ils aillent
se frotter au plus haut et donc en gros
sur des sur des combats l'échelle
mondiale et est tombé sur un sur un
promoteur et sur 1 sur un gros sponsor
qui lui permettent de passer plus vite
ces étapes là à 27 ans et s'est pas
encore forcément l'apogée pour un boxeur
mais mais il est
il est laid dont le rythme donc faux
fond ses 127 ans et ces jeunes je suis
d'accord mais c'est pas le même non plus
les numéro 3 français actuel voilà et
43e mondiale auxerre c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça que je disais c'est pas demain
qu'on va lui proposer une possibilité
d'aller chercher un titre mondial
donc il va falloir le temps quand même
encore quelques années ça va se jouer à
quelques années de plus on attend plus
on est impatient et et autres deux trois
ou quatre combats mais voilà donc
donc je dis encore pour quelques années
je pense que pavin pas vendre sa
trentaine et en lui proposant une
éventuelle possibilité d'être champion
vous n'avez pas peur que le promoteur
justement lui propose à gros combat très
rapidement trop vite contrat oryza
cadors voilà cette discipline voilà en
gris ou est ce qu'on sait très bien
qu'en boxe il faut plusieurs années
voire un jamais vain
voilà c'était face est impossible de
rattraper le retard qu'on a pris avec
une seule défaite l'an peux pas répondre
pour le promoteur
tout dépend le motif pour lequel il sera
proche de tony yoka si c'est pour en
faire un champion et le le suivre pour
vous pour arriver à ce qui arrive au
titre suprême
ou alors est ce qui le prend par rapport
à la médiatisation et pour faire un gros
coup justement est là où il serait pas
favori à lemaitre contre quelqu'un de un
grand boxeur
enfin d'autres dit je sois par exemple
si par exemple sa catégorie là par
contre
là par contre c'est pas la mer et c'est
pas le bon c'est pas le bon choix parce
que lui par contre là par contre ça pour
moi ça fuse giresse à sa carrière ce qui
gère quand même des carrières semblable
à celle de tony hawk a comme par exemple
tyson fury qui est un adversaire
potentiel pour tony hawk a justement
donc on ne sait pas il ya que pour
moteur qui peut répondre à ça on ne sait
pas le motif pour lequel il s'est
rapproché de lui que rien n'est encore
officiel or pour l'heure les ouï dire
exactement
alors on va passer maintenant notre page
débats sports de combat à présent la
ministre des sports annoncé qu'elle
souhaitait à légaliser la pratique des
arts martiaux mixtes en france pourtant
longtemps décriée est interdite il y
aurait à plusieurs centaines de
pratiquants dans les yvelines et
notamment à maurepas ou sdcl center le
mma soit rattachée à la fédération
française de boxe on écoute justement la
réaction du gérant du sdc health center
le choc a été donné c'est la boxe
anglaise s'était passé elle était donnée
gagnante du tout on est différents
sondages en fait à l'arrivée très très
très très loin
maintenant c'est un choix c'est un choix
et tant mieux parce qu'il fallait que ça
soit ça soit abandonnée délibéré il
fallait il fallait légiférer sur ça la
boxe anglaise c'est nous c'est une fédé
qui marche depuis très longtemps qui a
habitué à organiser des galas prom
professionnels un peu partout dans le
monde
si réellement ils les moyens sont mis
derrière pour développer le mma et
et tous qui toute la partie éducative
parce que le combat c'est bien mais
c'est toute la partie éducative c'est
comment comme encadrer des enfants
correctement dans les salles c'est si
les moyens sont mis par la fédé pour ça
c'est génial
dans tous les cas c'est un grand pas
pour le mma la question est simple pour
ou contre la légalisation du mba en
france peut-être avoir un duel enfin
petit duel entre stéphanie et pierre
stéphane d'abord bière je suis partagé
parce que c'est c'est donc c'est une
discipline
premièrement que je connais peu qu'à
travers un d'ailleurs un ancien
versailles et qui est parti en asie se
frotter se frottait justement d'abord la
boxe thaï depuis après aurait donc
peut-être on le verra à terme mais
partagés sur la maturité de ce sport
pour venir en france et celui qu'on
attendait juste avant par l'étude de la
formation et des enfants l'encadrement
et j'aimais juste se doute là en terme
de en termes de médiatisation il n'y a
pas de problème c'est connu par les
autres les pratiquants et leurs familles
c'est c'est une discipline convoi
indirectement parce qu'elle existe dans
d'autres pays
pour la france c'est peut-être prématuré
ou c'est peut-être un peu trop tôt pas
encore suffisamment préparée par rapport
à de la boxe ou ou à d'autres sports de
combat qui sont qui ont pignon sur rue
désormais en france doit laisser le
doute que j'aime et sur la capacité à
organiser correctement les combats
former correctement les jeunes et
encadrer cette pratique qui quoi qu'on
dise quoi qu'on dise et et quand même
particulière par rapport à d'autres
sports de combat comme la boxe ou la
boxe thaï pour ne citer que ceux là
stéphane cette avance que s'ils se sont
lancé là dedans c'est que c'est mûrement
réfléchie ils ont dû peser le pour et le
contre
ça va faire venir beaucoup de licenciés
et pourquoi pas faire à ce que ça ça
passe dès
je comment dire ça s'agrandissent et il
faut un point de départ et là c'est
l'occasion ou jamais je pense qu'ils ont
quand même mûrement réfléchi à ça qui
vous a convaincu vous était plus de la
ville stéphane en fait je rejoins les
deux après je pense que il faut comme
comme des et stéphane il faut commencer
c'est sur le pour moi la vraie question
c'est
la question de d'encadrer bien avec les
grandir les entraîneurs les les coachs
l'âge des participants les combats tout
ça c'est vraiment une discipline
particulière donc un petit peu trop flou
pour l'instant j'espère qu'ils ont
vraiment bien cadrer les choses et
qu'ils vont servir demain ils vont
servir un peu de demain de toutes les
situations rencontrées de peut-être de
ce qui se passe à l'étranger etc pour en
faire quelque chose de bien cadrer sinon
j'ai peur qu'ils aient un peu de
débordements que ce soit un petit peu
enfin les accidents sont vite arrivées
c'est un mélange de disciplines vraiment
d'impact de la boxe donc jeu il parlait
semaine surpris en fait le celui qui
était interviewé sous-marin aussi quitté
sur la soirée en fait et hésitent à se
marier quand on voit justement à l'écran
qui était survolée soirée était le
premier vainqueur d'un combat mma en
france c'était en 2015
il a remporté un quoi parce qu'il ya un
petit vide juridique qu'ils avaient
déposé de dossier au mois d'août
le dossier n'a pas été examiné par les
instances faute de personne et du coup
ils ont pu faire un combat au mois de
septembre
parce que si la manifestation n'est pas
interdite dans les deux semaines je
crois je crois qu'il ya une histoire de
délai on peut réaliser un combat et on a
été le premier vainqueur d'un combat et
mes bas en france officiellement
cqfd c'est un câble il faut il faut
encadrer cette pratique là il ya eu ce
vide se vide là qui a permis de 2,2
d'organiser de tenir ce que ce combat
mais s'il n'y avait qu'une seule fois en
plus ils m'ont pas ils m'ont par lui
même surpris de que ce sujet puisse
venir assez vite ça le ministre des
sports sont déchargées assez vite amis
c'est une sorte de mise sous tutelle de
la fédération française de boxe
[Musique]
c'est un petit ça sent pas très préparé
donc est-ce que c'est trop tôt je suis
d'avis je suis d'accord sur la partie
lancée lancées et préparées donner la
chance de mais est-ce que c'est pas là
actuellement un peu trop précipité mais
faut toujours un point de départ il faut
se lancer trop tard des clubs mais je
veux dire les participants des licenciés
a vu enfin oui mais à partir de quel âge
aux samoa c'est cette question aussi de
50000 pratiquants en france et pour
l'âge on peut le faire dès l'adolescence
ouais c'est ça après il faut vraiment
tout cadrer voire lenny enfin peut-être
qu'il ya des niveaux à mettre en place
je sais pas est ce que ça vous pensez
que ça va permettre à ce sport de se
développer encore plus cette
légalisation genre alors ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir aussi
c'est qu'il ya un petit problème de
faire un petit problème il ya surtout il
ya surtout une histoire de gros sous
l'eau dessous comme si parce que les
fédérations la fédération la boxe de
boxe pasquini seulement on voulait plus
que ça aille vers le kickboxing affaire
la fédération du boxing
c'est le ministère du sport qui a décidé
que ce serait attaché à la boxe anglaise
mais kaka et plus de ses licenciés il
faudra là il ya plus de licencié mais il
ya aussi une histoire une histoire
d'investissement et une histoire
d'argent
c'est à dire que la l'organisation de
combat va rapporter énormément d'argent
parce que c'est quand même une
discipline qui est attendu mine de rien
depuis très longtemps en france
c'est l'un des seuls payer la france
avoir longtemps interdit la boycotter à
la télévision je tends pas de pratiquer
mais et donc c'est très attendu et je
crois que là au niveau international ils
ont vraiment il c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
que c'est allé assez vite parce qu'il ya
quand même là dessous un des gros
intérêts financiers et
je pense que justement je rejoins
pierres lorsqu'ils disaient que à
vouloir aller trop vite et faire en
risque le faire n'importe quoi donc
attention parce qu'il faut que ce soit
bien encadré c'est quand même un sport
qui est quand même sport à risques
pierre pas mieux alors il ya de la mode
pendant l'interview on n'a pas vu qu'on
a vu précédemment disais que la
fédération française de boxe n'était pas
forcément le choix le choix principal
pour vous est ce qu est ce qu est ce que
pour vous vous seriez se répartit sur le
kick boxing
ça semble plus proche de kickboxing ne
serait ce que par l'utilisation déjà
physique du corps c'est tous les membres
au kick et pas en boxe anglaise et qu'à
la boxe française savate rond qu'on
envoie les pieds donc cc oui c'est plus
est plus proche d'un d'un combat
kickboxing éventuellement de bob stein
mais vous placez là c'est plus dans
l'est dans la partie franco française
ce sera été plus logique d'aller vers un
terrain sport qui ressemble qui lui
ressemble justement parce qu'ils les ont
ils les ont raccroché à la boxe parce
que je pense que c'est la fédération a
peut-être la mieux structurée de d2 ce
genre de sport de combat et c'est pour
ça que justement ils ont quand même un
petit petit petit doute sur on en a pas
trop parlé autour de cette table mais
pourquoi le mma et ses interdits
précédemment
c'était à cause de la dangerosité de ce
sport est également
est ce que vous pensez stéphane est ce
que vous pensez que ce sport est trop
dangereux il est très violent mais après
maints ses seins sport comme un autre
donc voilà peu plus violent que la boxe
rond
moi je pense qu'il est plus violent que
la boxe après bon voilà ses côtés tout
est permis de tout envoyer un peu tout
envoyer ou ici c'est quand même des feux
pour avoir vu quelques combats comme
salaire pendant tier parmentier mais
quelques bribes
c'est du costaud il ya là m'a dit
pendant cette interview là que le rugby
était aussi violent que le mba est ce
qu'ont confirmé les de rugbyman
ruby est aussi violent un rugby un rugby
c'est physique
c'est physique a pour moi le rugby et
physique mais pas violent au delà il n'y
a pas d'âge
s'il n'y a pas de coups puis vient pas
de quoi peut-être été sur les chocs les
choquer les les collisions contact
encore mais déjà déjà c'est à 15 contre
15 et au rugby
là ces deux là c'est un contre un où
quasiment tout est permis un jeu il me
semble plus de règles au rugby qu'il n'y
en a même
et puis aujourd'hui la ligne de touche
on peut sortir la laque à son bord
décide à la question ce qu'il faut une
version classique du mma ou est-ce qu'il
faut une version édulcorée pour la
france alors tous passé c'est soit on
fait soit on fait pas mais par contre
pour moi hyper cadres et
arbitrer mais vraiment de façon précise
je pense que c'est ça un peu finalement
comme rugby les la façon de voir
d'observer de tout de suite dire quand
il ya quelque chose mais non je pense
que on peut pas faire du nni dulko et
c'est pas du même nom n'est pas la
personne c'est pas du tout le l'objectif
m je le dis c'est pas du tout l'objectif
est mais pour moi c'est ce qu'ont fait
ou on fait pas je rejoins l'un des
demi-mesures par deux mesures c'est le
fait chez c'est comme ça que ça les gens
que ça fera venir du monde
si on commence à faire des noeuds des
règles à nous on va s'en tirer une balle
dans le pied
automatique pour enlever les peaux la
télé qui règle peut être imposée dès des
règles on verrait la reine en dieu est
mort l'autre vision il y en a beaucoup
maintenant en france mais c'est pas ton
est en phase mais c'est accessible en
france il ya des chaînes les mêmes
arrêts on va terminer comme d'habitude
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui en hommage aux
basketteurs kobe bryant star des lakers
mort avec sa fille dans un accident
d'hélicoptère
je vous propose une de ses citations les
héros vont et viennent mais les légendes
sont éternels une petite réaction sur
kobe bryant autour de cette table
tragique tragique pour vous la livre est
tragique c'est ainsi nous ne s'est
hissée jusqu'au bout dans la légende
tiens même dans sa disparition c'est une
opération tragique évidemment beaucoup
trop tôt 41 ans avec sa fille
il laisse une famille derrière il est ce
énormément d'orphelins à los angeles
qu'est ce qu'ils représentaient pour
vous agents une icône au même titre que
michael jordan dans le même sport
c'était c'était un monsieur du monde du
monde du basket qui s'emballe basket un
dieux du basket qui nous quitte
moi j'étais pas trop compris o'brian moi
je suis plus lakers magic johnson et
tout ça je suivais pas trop la carrière
de kobe mais on en parlait beaucoup
envoyer les images et je comprends que
ça a été une onde de choc
par contre le son décès c'est je trouve
ça bête partir comme ça je trouve ça
bête
hélène bossy a présenté à mieux faire
mieux non mais c'est vrai toutes façons
les grandes les grands noms de clubs de
sport et de qui représente vraiment
toute une jeune génération un sport les
disparitions voilà c'est ça laisse ça
laisse forcément ça devient des légendes
évidemment après voilà comme tu disais
c'est bête même temps choisi pour éviter
les embouteillages
vous arrivez alors je rappelle la
citation les rôles et heroes vi vont et
viennent mais les légendes sont éternels
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]
oui